estos niños del centro médico de
guatemalani juegan en un raro momento de
alivio sufren cáncer y huyeron dejar Tum
y de la Guerra el hospital oncológico de
la capital tuvo que cerrar
a medida que la guerra empeoraba ya no
había medicinas los médicos Ya no
estaban allí tuvimos suerte de que nos
trasladaran aquí a madani y gracias a
Dios Aquí hay médicos y estamos a salvo
como el hijo de adulación entre 1500 y
2000 niños recibían tratamiento cada mes
en la capital unos 350 de ellos llegaron
aquí para continuar su tratamiento pero
aunque la ciudad se salvó de los
combates el hospital se enfrenta a
grandes carencias
cuando los niños llegaron al hospital
descansaron un poco e intentamos
reanudar su tratamiento les dimos lo que
había disponible no tenemos acceso a
todos los medicamentos el 80% de los
productos necesarios no están
disponibles no podemos tratar gran
mayoría lo único que podemos hacer es
decirles que tengan paciencia y esperen
antes de la guerra los niños de familias
ricas iban a Egipto o Europa en busca de
tratamiento la escasez ya era habitual
en Sudán una ong consiguió constituir
una reserva de medicamentos para tratar
algunos tipos de cáncer pero suficiente
solo para unos seis meses
El problema es que cuando se administra
un tratamiento un niño luego se acaba y
los pacientes pueden esperar mucho
tiempo ante este poder seguir con el
tratamiento es un retroceso de todos los
progresos realizados anteriormente y la
salud de los niños
empeoraba con una cantante
el número de nuevos casos de cáncer en
Sudán ha ido creciendo en los últimos
años miles de niños podrían morir debido
a la falta de medicamentos por causa de
la guerra